Hello and welcome to speaking of psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Audrey Hamilton. In this episode, I talk with a psychologist about why climate change scientists, communicators, and policymakers should be looking at older adults as an untapped resource for green thinking. A lot of the research has overlooked older people in the climate discussion. I find that I'm either an aging whisperer to climate groups or a climate. climate whisper to aging groups because both groups are sort of like ships passing in the night. They're not talking to each other.
你好，欢迎收听《心理学说话》，这是一档由美国心理学会制作的播客。我是主持人奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。在本期节目中，我和一位心理学家进行了交谈，探讨了为什么气候变化科学家、传播者和政策制定者应该将老年人视为绿色思考的未开发资源。许多研究在气候讨论中忽视了老年人。我发现自己要么是气候群体中的老龄化低语者，要么是气候群体中的气候低语者。气候低语者指向老龄化群体，因为这两群人有点像在夜里擦肩而过的船只。他们互不交流。
In fact, psychology research has shown that older adults are primed to think about their own legacies and future generations. And while older adults also are more likely to vote and have time to act on climate change-related issues, they are usually left feeling anxious, invisible, and undervalued. Mick Smyer, a professor of psychology at Bucknell University, has leveraged his work in gerontology, the study of aging, into developing and evaluating effective climate action strategies for an aging world. His graying green project works with climate communicators, climate scientists, and community and business leaders to make older adults more visible, valued, and effective in climate action strategies. Welcome, Dr. Smire.
事实上，心理学研究表明，老年人已准备好思考他们自己的遗产和子孙后代。尽管老年人也更有可能投票并有时间对气候变化相关问题采取行动，但他们通常会感到焦虑、隐形和被低估。巴克内尔大学心理学教授米克·斯迈尔（Mick Smyer）利用他在老年学（研究老龄化的学科）方面的工作，为老龄化世界开发和评估有效的气候行动策略。“灰绿项目”与气候传播者、气候科学家以及社区和商业领袖合作，使老年人在气候行动策略中更加显眼、更有价值、更具成效。欢迎你，斯迈尔博士。
Thanks for having me. I think there's an assumption out there that younger people are more concerned about the negative repercussions of climate change. You know, yet a recent survey done at Yale said that 45, 35% of baby boomers are alarmed or concerned about climate change compared with just 35% of millennials, just as one example. Does this surprise you or why or why not? Well, that's a good question, Audrey. It does not surprise me, but I'm biased. I'm a gerontologist. I've been studying aging my whole career. So I know that older adults are thinking about the future, even if they're not going to be part of that future, even if their own time is shorter than the future they can envision. I also know that developmentally, older adults are primed to think about next generations in their own family. So for those reasons, I'm not surprised that older adults are concerned about climate change and climate action in general.
谢谢邀请我来。我认为人们有一种假设，即年轻人更关心气候变化的负面影响。你知道，耶鲁大学最近做的一项调查表明，45%、35%的婴儿潮一代对气候变化感到惊慌或担忧，而千禧一代只有35%，这只是一个例子。这让你感到惊讶吗？为什么或者为什么不？嗯，这是一个好问题，奥黛丽。这并不让我感到惊讶，但我有偏见。我是一名老年学家。我的整个职业生涯都在研究老龄化。所以我知道老年人在思考未来，即使他们不会成为那个未来的一部分，即使他们自己的时间比他们能想象的未来还要短。我也知道，在发展心理学上，老年人天然倾向于考虑他们自己家庭中的下一代。由于这些原因，我对老年人普遍关注气候变化和气候行动并不感到惊讶。
And then when you get to very specific actions in their local or regional communities or that affect them or their families, I'm not surprised that their concern is even higher. The number of people aged 60 and older has doubled since 1980. the number of people aged 80 years and older, well, almost quadruple to 395 million between now and 2050. You have said that older populations are a largely ignored resource for climate change efforts. What does the research say about older adults and the likelihood that they would become interested in environmentalism? Well, it's interesting. A lot of the research has overlooked older people in the climate discussion. I find that I'm either an aging whisper to climate groups or a climate whisper to,
然后，当谈到他们当地或区域社区中非常具体的行动，或者影响他们及其家人的行动时，我并不奇怪他们的关注度甚至更高。自1980年以来，60岁及以上的人口数量已经翻了一番。到2050年，80岁及以上的人口数量将几乎翻两番，达到3.95亿。你说过，老年人口在气候变化努力中是一个在很大程度上被忽视的资源。研究对老年人及其对环保主义产生兴趣的可能性有什么看法？嗯，这很有趣。许多研究在气候讨论中忽视了老年人。我发现自己要么是气候群体老龄化的低语者，要么是气候群体的低语者，
aging groups because both groups are sort of like ships passing in the night. They're not talking to each other. So when I first started the Gray and Green Project, I talked to climate scientists and I talk about the intersection of population aging and climate change, two global patterns, and I get a one-word answer. And that word was, huh. And the first time I got that word, I was a little worried. But then I realized that, huh, is science talk for? That's not a crazy idea. I just never thought of it. And so we'd go on and talk, and then the climate scientist would become intrigued by what are we missing here? And I think what they're missing is that a lot of the lessons that they've developed for other age groups also apply to older people. The basic
老龄化群体，因为这两个群体有点像夜里擦肩而过的船只。他们互不交流。所以当我刚开始“灰绿项目”时，我和气候科学家交谈，我谈到了人口老龄化和气候变化的交集，这两个全球模式，我得到了一个字的回答。那个词是，哈。我第一次听到这个词时，我有点担心。但后来我意识到，“哈”是科学界的说法，意思是？这并不是一个疯狂的想法。我只是从来没有想过。所以我们继续谈话，然后气候科学家开始对我们错过了什么产生好奇？我认为他们错过的是，他们为其他年龄段制定的许多教训也适用于老年人。最基本的
lesson that comes from the National Academy of Sciences, for example, is when it comes to climate communication, keep it short, social, and positive. Here's what that means. Short in terms of time frame, we're not wired to think about our carbon footprint 10,000 years from now. In fact, we can think maybe three or four generations out, so short time frame really matters. Social, we're more likely to engage older people if we can link the climate issue to people and places that they care about, that they have a social connection to. And positive, it's really important not to leave people totally overwhelmed with anxiety by how big the climate issue is, but it's important to point out the realities and also to point out what can we do about it,
例如，美国国家科学院得出的教训是，在气候沟通方面，要做到简短、社交和积极。这就是含义。在时间框架方面要简短，我们的头脑天生不习惯考虑一万年后的碳足迹。事实上，我们或许能考虑到未来三到四代人，所以简短的时间框架真的很重要。社交，如果我们能将气候问题与他们在乎的人和地方、与他们有社交联系的人和地方联系起来，我们就更有可能让老年人参与进来。积极，真正重要的是不要让人们被气候问题的大小彻底压垮焦虑，但指出现实以及指出我们能做些什么也很重要，
What are some positive steps that individuals and communities can take? So as you mentioned, you're the founder of the Gray and Green Project. Could you tell me a bit more about the goals of that project and what you're doing to achieve those goals? Sure. Gray and Green is really designed to try to move older people from anxiety to action to habit on climate change. And we're doing that by engaging both climate scientists and climate communicators in this work. and also developing some specific approaches and testing them out. I spent the last year or so at the design school at Stanford University
个人和社区可以采取哪些积极的步骤？正如你所提到的，你是“灰绿项目”的创始人。你能多告诉我一些关于该项目目标的事情，以及你正在做什么来实现这些目标吗？当然。灰绿项目旨在尝试引导老年人在气候变化问题上从焦虑走向行动再到习惯。我们通过让气候科学家和气候传播者都参与到这项工作中来实现这一点。同时也开发一些具体的方法并进行测试。我在斯坦福大学设计学院度过了大约过去的一年，
really trying to take design thinking and design concepts and applying it to this civic engagement issue. And in that process, I spent a lot of time talking with older people about their concerns and about their feeling that they're invisible, undervalued, and ineffective on climate issues. and then working with them to figure out, well, how can we change that? How can we move them from that anxiety about climate to action and then habit on climate change? And we now have a set of approaches that work.
真正试图将设计思维和设计概念应用到这个公民参与的问题中。在这个过程中，我花了很多时间与老年人交流他们的担忧，以及他们对自己在气候问题上感到隐形、被低估和无效的感受。然后与他们合作，找出答案，嗯，我们如何改变这一点？我们如何让他们从对气候的焦虑转向行动，再到对气候变化的习惯？我们现在有一套行之有效的方法。
And now our next step is how do we scale that from working with individuals or small groups to larger groups and communities. So what are some examples of the approaches that you're looking at? Well, let me ask you four questions, Audrey. Very simple questions. Okay. No podcast hosts will be harmed in the making of this. recording. Picture a place, any place in the world that has a special meaning to you that you're really attached to. You have that place in mind? Yeah. Okay. Picture that place affected by extreme
现在我们的下一步是如何将其从与个人或小集团合作扩展到更大的群体和社区。那么你们正在研究的方法有哪些例子呢？好吧，奥黛丽，让我问你四个问题。非常简单的问题。好的。在这个录音制作过程中，不会有任何播客主持人受到伤害。想象一个地方，世界上任何对你有特殊意义、让你非常依恋的地方。你脑子里有那个地方了吗？是的。好的。想象那个地方受到极端
weather or climate change. Can you picture that threat? Yes. Okay. Now picture what you'd like that place to look like 40 to 50 years from now, not what you think it will look like, but what you'd like it to look like. Okay. You have that picture in mine? And fourth and final question, for the bonus round, picture something you can do today to work towards that vision that you have for 40 to 50 years from now.
天气或气候变化的影响。你能想象那种威胁吗？是的。好的。现在想象一下，四五十年后你希望那个地方是什么样子，不是你认为它会是什么样子，而是你希望它是什么样子。好的。你脑子里有那幅画吗？第四个也是最后一个问题，作为附加题，想象一下你今天可以做些什么来朝着你对四五十年后的愿景努力。
Okay. Yeah. Can you picture something? A little bit. Maybe. So I'd have to think about it maybe. A little bit longer, but it gets you thinking, right? Exactly.
好的。是的。你能想象出什么吗？有一点。也许吧。所以我可能得考虑一下。再久一点，但它让你开始思考，对吧？正是如此。
So this is the first step of a three-step process that we've developed. Those four questions I've done with hundreds of people now. now, everybody can do the first three. Regardless of political stripe, regardless of viewpoints on a variety of other issues, everybody has a place in the world they care about, and everybody knows what the threat is to that place. And by the way, I've just made it personal for you, and in 40 to 50-year time frame, I've made it short for you. So you're thinking back to the National Academy of Sciences, and you're already thinking short and social. But now the fourth question is the stumper.
所以这是我们开发的三步流程的第一步。这四个问题我现在已经和数百人谈过了。每个人都可以完成前三个。无论政治派别如何，无论对各种其他问题的观点如何，世界上每个人都有一个在乎的地方，每个人都知道对那个地方的威胁是什么。顺便说一句，我刚刚把它变得对你来说很私密，在40到50年的时间框架内，我把它变得很短。所以你回想起美国国家科学院，你已经在想着简短和社交了。但现在第四个问题是难题。
What can you do to work towards that vision? I would say 85 to 90% of people are stumped with that question. They don't know what to do. Now, as a clinical psychologist, if I just left you anxious, it's pretty good for business, but it's not very good for climate action. And that's where the second step comes in. We've developed a set of procedures, a card sorting task, which is kind of fun, that helps people figure out first what are they already doing on climate?
你能做些什么来朝着那个愿景努力？我想85%到90%的人都会被这个问题难倒。他们不知道该怎么办。现在，作为一名临床心理学家，如果我只让你感到焦虑，这对生意挺好，但对气候行动却不太好。这就是第二步发挥作用的地方。我们开发了一套程序，一种卡片分类任务，这有点有趣，可以帮助人们首先弄清楚他们已经在气候方面做了什么？
And second, what's their next step on their own climate journey? and when we work that through with people, when we take them through that card sorting task, we find a couple of things happen. They really enjoy doing it. And as one 73-year-old said to me recently, I was delighted to see how much I'm already doing, but I was even more delighted to figure out what my next step was.
其次，他们在自己的气候之旅中的下一步是什么？当我们和人们一起完成这个任务时，当我们带他们完成那个卡片分类任务时，我们发现了几件有趣的事情。他们真的很喜欢做这件事。正如最近一位73岁的老人对我说的那样，我很高兴看到自己已经做了这么多，但我更高兴的是弄清楚了我的下一步是什么。
And then the third part of our process is what we call a climate commitment. It's a psychology, behavioral economics, straight engagement contract, where we get people to say, here's my next step. So who am I going to share that goal with? And when am I going to do it? What's the time frame? And then the last part, which is kind of fun, is we ask people to picture a person or an organization whose values, visions, and goals they do not agree with. They disagree with. And then make a commitment of a certain dollar amount that they will pledge to that person
然后我们流程的第三部分是我们所说的气候承诺。这是一个心理学、行为经济学、直接参与的契约，我们让人们说，这是我的下一步。那么我要和谁分享这个目标呢？我什么时候去做？时间框架是什么？然后最后一部分，挺有趣的，我们要求人们想象一个他们不同意其价值观、愿景和目标的个人或组织。他们不同意。然后承诺一定金额的钱，他们会发誓给那个人
or organization if they don't carry through on the goal that they've just set. and usually when I ask them to identify an organization or person they don't agree with, there's nervous laughter in the room. I'll give you one quick example, then I'll stop. I was doing this exercise at a retirement community in State College, Pennsylvania, which football fans would know is the home of Penn State. And when we got to the climate commitment part, I asked people to identify an organization or individual whose goals they didn't agree with,
或组织，如果他们没有兑现刚刚设定的目标。通常当我让他们确定一个他们不同意其观点的组织或个人时，房间里会有紧张的笑话。我给你举一个简单的例子，然后我就停下来。我在宾夕法尼亚州州立学院的一个退休社区做这个练习，美式足球迷会知道那是宾夕法尼亚州立大学的所在地。当我们进入气候承诺部分时，我要求人们确定一个他们不同意其目标的组织或个人，
and somebody wrote down Ohio State University. So now, from the outside, I could not have predicted that Ohio State would be a motivator for an older adult on climate change. But that person has told me what will motivate them. And it turns out that this combination of the first four questions I asked you, the card sort and the climate contract, is very effective in moving people from anxiety to action to habit on climate change. Finally, I want to talk about something that isn't often brought up in conversations about climate change. And this is the physical and mental consequences of climate change. Earlier this year, the APA issued a report with EcoAmerica,
有人写下俄亥俄州立大学。所以现在，从局外来看，我不可能预测俄亥俄州立大学会成为老年人在气候变化方面的动力。但那个人告诉我什么会激励他们。事实证明，我问你的前四个问题的组合、卡片分类和气候契约，在促使人们在气候变化问题上从焦虑走向行动再到习惯方面非常有效。最后，我想谈谈一个在气候变化对话中经常被提及的话题。这就是气候变化带来的身心后果。今年早些时候，美国心理学会与EcoAmerica联合发布了一份报告，
outlining the potential impact of climate change on mental health. Are older adults more vulnerable to these changes? Is that something that you've looked at and studied? Well, that's a very good point, Audrey. Older adults are more vulnerable to a variety of effects of both physical and mental health effects of climate change. In fact, there have been a number of studies, including the most recent study by Eco-American and American Cyclone,
概述了气候变化对心理健康的潜在影响。老年人更容易受到这些变化的影响吗？这是你研究和研究过的事情吗？嗯，这是一个很好的观点，奥黛丽。老年人在气候变化的身体和心理健康效应方面更容易受到各种影响。事实上，已经有很多研究，包括Eco-American和美国精神病学协会最近的研究
Psychological Association that highlight the special vulnerabilities of older adults. The way that I think about this is following the lead of the Department of Defense. The Department of Defense says that climate change is a threat multiplier, a strategic threat multiplier. And I think when you look at older people, they are particularly vulnerable because they are more likely to have chronic health conditions, although the rates of mental illness are lower in later life than in other parts of the lifespan. When they occur, they're likely to be as difficult and a challenge to respond to as at other parts of the lifespan. So older adults are vulnerable in many of the same ways and have some additional physical vulnerabilities, like a lessened ability to deal with heat stress, for example,
心理学协会强调了老年人的特殊脆弱性。我思考这个问题的方式是效仿国防部的做法。国防部表示，气候变化是一个威胁乘数，一个战略威胁乘数。我认为当你审视老年人时，他们特别脆弱，因为他们更有可能患有慢性健康状况，尽管晚年心理疾病的发病率低于生命周期的其他部分。当它们发生时，它们可能像生命周期的其他部分一样困难和具有挑战性。因此，老年人在许多相同的方面都很脆弱，并且有一些额外的身体脆弱性，例如应对热应力的能力减弱，例如
and thermoregulation in a heat wave and that sort of thing. What gray and green is trying to do, however, is to say, yes, the threats are real, and older adults are vulnerable, but older adults are not only victims of climate change, but potential leaders of climate action. So both are true. The one thing I would point out is that the recent report by Eco America and APA, which Susan Clayton and Christy Manning chaired from the APA, continues APA's work in this area. Janet Swim and her colleagues published an earlier report. port. And one of the key themes there is building resilience, both at the individual and community level. And in many ways, that's what gray and green is about, trying to help individuals become more resilient and through older people and their circles of influence, helping communities become more resilient in the face of climate change. Okay, well, Dr. Smire, thank you so much for joining us. It's been a real pleasure. Thanks, Audrey. I've enjoyed it. Thanks for listening to our podcast. Make sure you check out our other episodes of Speaking of Psychology,
以及热浪中的体温调节等等。然而，灰绿项目试图做的是，是的，威胁是真实的，老年人是脆弱的，但老年人不仅是气候变化的受害者，也是气候行动的潜在领导者。所以两者都是真的。我要指出的第一件事是，Eco America和APA最近的报告由APA的苏珊·克莱顿和克里斯蒂·曼宁主持，延续了APA在该领域的 Arbeit 工作。珍妮特·斯威姆和她的同事发表了一早期的报告。端口。其中一个关键主题是建设复原力，包括个人和社区层面。在许多方面，这就是灰绿项目的主旨，试图帮助个人变得更有弹性，并通过老年人及其影响力圈子，帮助社区在面对气候变化时变得更有弹性。好的，斯迈尔博士，非常感谢您加入我们。这真的是一种荣幸。谢谢，奥黛丽。我很享受。感谢收听我们的播客。请务必查看我们的其他《心理学说话》剧集，
and please subscribe if you haven't already. We are a proud member of the APA Podcast Network, which includes other great podcasts. Please check out APA Journal's Dialogue if you want to hear about the latest and most exciting psychology research. And if you're interested in the practice of psychology, you can listen to Progress Notes.
如果你还没有订阅，请订阅。我们是APA播客网络的骄傲成员，其中包含其他精彩的播客。如果您想了解最新、最令人兴奋的心理学研究，请查看APA期刊的《对话》。如果您对心理学实践感兴趣，您可以收听《进度记录》。
Topics include how healthcare policy and social media affect practicing psychologists. You can find those podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingof psychology.org to listen to even more episodes and gather more resources on the topics we discussed. Thanks for joining us. I'm Audrey Hamilton with the American Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
主题包括医疗保健政策和社交媒体如何影响执业心理学家。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或您获取播客的任何地方找到这些播客。您也可以访问我们的网站speakingof psychology.org收听更多剧集，并收集有关我们讨论的主题的更多资源。感谢您的加入。我是美国心理学会的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学说话》。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。